hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easy görmin wir
sind heute wieder in köln und erinnert
euch letztes mal haben wir mit rami m
video gemacht
rami ist heute zurück wie geht's dir wir
haben ein neues thema für euch und zwar
wollen wir heute mal was machen zum
thema deutsche aussprache auch ein
interessantes thema wir haben uns heute
vorgenommen das ch mit euch zu üben
und dazu gibt es verschiedene
aussprachen
denn es hängt immer davon ab wo das ch
steht bzw welchen vokal man vor dem ch
hat dementsprechend spricht man das
manchmal anders aus rami schnitt heute
mal mit uns heraus wie man das land
spricht und wir fragen leute auf der
straße und bitten sie uns zu helfen
dani fangen wir an was geht
wir fangen an mit dem ersten ch und zwar
ist das das ch nach einem oder oder
das wird nämlich vorne gebildet und ist
sehr weich also quasi hier wird das
gebildet beispiel ich sprechen sprechen
michael michael sehr gut rami
ich bin hier am bahnhof
ich gehe gerne zum sport ich gebe einen
interview ich habe ein haustier milch
ich trinke gerne milch ist lecker milch
milch macht müde männer munter chemie in
der schule hatte ich chemieunterricht
chemie ist schwer china in china wird
chinesisch gesprochen
china china liegt am ende der welt wenn
in china ein sack reis umfällt dann
interessiert uns das hier nicht küche in
der küche koche ich viel küche
deine küche werden lebensmittel
zubereitet küche in der küche mache ich
mir meistens meinem opa tino sprechen
ich spreche gerade mit euch sprechen
gespräche mit dir michael michels alter
kumpel von mir ich kenne einen freund
der heißt michael michael ich kenne kein
michael kirche ich gehe nicht so häufig
in die kirche kirche sonntags gehe ich
in die kirche küche neben mir ist eine
kirche manche manche menschen verstehen
keinen spaß
manche manche leute machen viel sport
geschichte im geschichte habe ich nicht
immer so gut aufgepasst geschichte mein
lieblingsfach ist geschichte geschichte
mir fällt keine gute geschichte ein
unser zweites ch für heute ist das ch
was man nach so genannten dunklen
lokalen spricht nämlich nach a und o
das wird hinten gebildet nämlich zum
beispiel machen machen geruch geruch und
doch noch machen
ich mache mir warme gedanken was ist
kalt hier machen
ich mache gerne essen machen
er macht meistens gar nichts auf dem
dach hab ich früher gearbeitet weil ich
bin von beruf dachdecker mein haus hat
einen tag
jedes haus hat ein dach hoch jeder
mensch hat seinen persönlichen geruch
der geruch von ihm ist nicht so viel
doch diese tasche hat ein loch ich falle
in ein loch loch er viele doch buch ich
lese ein buch mein gepäck ist eingepackt
in ein tuch ich trockne das mit einem
tuch ab doch der koch macht meistens
lecker essen
doch wenn ich in ein restaurant gehe
kocht der koch für mich das essen kocht
man kann lernen gut zu kochen doch doch
meine freundin kann nicht alles doch so
mannschaft nicht immer alles hoch der
dom ist sehr hoch
der dom ist hoch
die alpen sind sehr hoch nachher zum
lachen gehe ich in den keller
ich lache viel lachen lachen macht spaß
sachen sachen habe ich an sachen ich
habe viele sachen in meinem
kleiderschrank sachen ich habe wenige
sachen rauchen rauchend durch nicht auch
wenn rauchen ist ungesund machen kann es
wirklich sein ja jetzt habt ihr gerade
die beiden standard aussprachen von ch
im deutschen gesehen aber es gibt noch
zwei ausnahmen die erste ausnahme das
spricht man ch wie ein k
zum beispiel in core core oder wachsen
wachsen
chor zu weihnachten singt der chor in
der kirche chronisch chronisch chronisch
meine nase läuft chronisch charisma
charisma du hast sehr viel charisma
wachsen wachsen
wachsen wenn ich snowboarden gehe wachse
ich mein snowboard wechseln
wechsel wechsel ja bäumchen wechsel dich
sagt man und die vierte und letzte
ausnahme für heute das betrifft wörter
die aus fremdsprachen kommen zum
beispiel portugiesisch oder französisch
oder italienisch dort wird das ch
manchmal wie ein ausgesprochen also das
deutsche sch beispiel champignons
lampion oder macho macho charlotte
charlotte kalla droht arbeitet beim wdr
champignon champignon champignon
champignon mag ich gern mit zwiebeln und
butter angebraten macho macho
macho
bin ich gar nicht nein ein macho bin ich
gar nicht
recherche recherche
ja das war unsere heutige episode und
wir hoffen sehr dass sie euch geholfen
hat das ch im deutschen richtig
auszusprechen
wir sind mittlerweile wieder zurück in
berlin die abmoderation haben wir leider
vergessen aber ihr fragt euch jetzt
sicher wer ist eigentlich rami wir haben
euch am anfang gesagt dass er ihn schon
kennt aber ihr kennt ihn gar nicht die
antwort ist wir haben schon mal eine
episode mit ihm gedreht und die wurde
aber leider noch nicht gezeigt deswegen
für euch rami ist ein zuschauer genau
wie ihr
und er kommt aus syrien bis 14 jahre alt
ist erst seit einem jahr in deutschland
und spricht schon sehr sehr gutes
deutsch
und ja er hat uns geschrieben genau das
gleiche könnt ihr auch tun wenn ihr mal
co-moderator wie sie german werden wollt
schreibt uns einfach an info at easy -
languages dot org und vielleicht seid
ihr das nächste mal auch dabei wenn ihr
mehr easy german sehen wollt subscribe
hier unten auf unseren kanal wenn ihr
uns unterstützen wollt dann klickt hier
unten mal bei patrick amrhein dort könnt
ihr zum beispiel auch outtakes und
extras zu dieser episode sehen und zu
vielen anderen
danke fürs zuschauen und bis nächste
woche